I had moved from Chicago which was kind
of the uh this Lily white suburb of
Chicago to Northwest Indiana so it was
culture shock and it was pretty brutal
it was a pretty rude awakening like I
think I was like the strongest kid in
fifth grade and then I arrived and I was
like nothing
and so that's where I think I really I
had your sixth grade basically your
middle school years you start in Indiana
yeah in the middle of fifth grade and I
had some jokes that we you know had you
know you learn as little kids so that
was
I was trying to get an adjective before
pale you know what I mean so it was like
the funny pale kid right right you know
that new pale kids
you know so it's that new real white kid
so I was trying real one an adjective
the Honeydew with Ryan sickler